multilatéralisme renforcer soutien accru
à la lutte contre la pandémie
voici les grandes lignes de ce g7
virtuel pour son premier sommet avec les
alliés traditionnels de l'amérique joe
biden la firme
les etats unis sont de retour dans les
relations transatlantiques
l'amérique est de retour
l'alliance transatlantique et de retour
et nous ne regardons pas en arrière nous
regardons ensemble vers l'avenir
ce qui revient à dire que cette alliance
transatlantique est une base solide au
fondement solide sur lequel repose notre
sécurité collective et notre prospérité
partagée au coeur des interventions
l'aide apportée pour lutter contre la
pandémie mondiale aux pays les plus
pauvres avec notamment un soutien de 7,5
milliards de dollars ajoutés aux 1,5
milliard de dollars supplémentaire
apportée par l'allemagne
dans un communiqué commun les pays
membres ont plaidé en faveur d'une
collaboration plus étroite entre états
nous allons travailler ensemble avec les
autres pour faire de 2021 un tournant
pour le multilatéralisme et pour
façonner une reprise qui promeuvent la
santé et la prospérité de nos peuples et
de notre planète
lors de ce g7 emmanuel macron a de
nouveau condamné l'inégalité d'accès aux
vaccins le président de la république a
proposé de donner suffisamment de doses
pour protéger toutes les populations le
continent africain à 6,5 millions de
soignants il faut 13 millions de doses
de vaccins pour les protéger permettre
au système de soins de résister si nous
européens américains nous savons livrer
le plus vite possible c'est 13 millions
de doses ça vaut énormément ça vaut
notre crédibilité
ça représente 0,43 pour cent des doses
que nous avons commandé
si nous savons faire ça alors l'ouest
aura une présence et sera considérée en
afrique
si nous annonçons des milliards
aujourd'hui pour donner des doses dans
six mois dans huit mois dans un an
nos amis africains auront sous la
pression de leurs populations et à juste
titre acheté des doses aux chinois ou
aux russes ou directement à d'autres
labos
ratoire pipe des annonces évidemment
saluée par l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
nous avons besoin que les gouvernements
financent entièrement le kovacs et
qu'ils fassent des dons maintenant nous
sommes reconnaissants des annonces
faites aujourd'hui par plusieurs pays du
g7 l'équité en matière de vaccin n'est
pas seulement la bonne chose à faire
c'est aussi la chose intelligente à
faire d'autres vaccins sont en cours de
développement d'approbation et de
production il y en aura assez pour tout
le monde mais pour l'instant les vaccins
sont une ressource limitée
nous devons les utiliser aussi
efficacement que possible au coeur des
débats depuis plusieurs jours les
inégalités face à l'accès à la
vaccination pour lutter contre le
comique 19 ont semblé préoccuper le g7
une prise de position saluée est suivi
par tous durant ce g7 virtuel mais qui
devraient être suivies d'actes concrets